Знаменита операція "Спис НептУна" у травні 2011-го.
Президент Барак Обама та усі ключові силовики наживо стежать за ліквідацією
лідера "Аль-Каїди" Осами бен Ладена.
У куточку серед інших і Ентоні Блінкен, тоді ще радник віцепрезидента Байдена з питань безпеки.
За десять років його роль неабияк зросла. Його завдання нині теж значно масштабніші.
Дипломат з українським корінням 26 січня очолив Держдепартамент - міністерство закордонних справ США.
У питанні України, а також щодо агресії Росії та незаконної анексії Криму,
дипломат чітко позиціонував себе від самого початку.
Як і багато наших міжнародних партнерів, США ще раз категорично повторюють просту істину: Крим - це Україна.
5-6 травня держсекретар Сполучених Штатів Ентоні Блінкен відвідує Україну в межах свого європейського турне.
Президент Джо Байден не раз давав зрозуміти, що Україна буде
одним із пріоритетів американської зовнішньої політики.
Але чого конкретно вдалося досягти за перші 100 днів новій владі?
Чому такий важливий візит Блінкена до Києва? І яких імпульсів Україні ще чекати від США?
Україна в фокусі Вашингтона значно більше присутня, ніж за часів Обами і Трампа.
Перелік зробленого адміністрацією Джо Байдена за символічні сто днів урядування
в цьому напрямку вражає експертів.
Не слід забувати, що у Байдена та Блінкена на порядку денному - дуже багато питань.
Не лише у зовнішній, але й у внутрішній політиці.
І той факт, що вони приділяють таку увагу Україні, має велике значення.
Вже у квітні цього року Блінкен постав перед першим серйозним викликом.
Російська Федерація зосередила більше 100 тисяч військових на кордоні з Україною та у Криму.
Західні експерти переконані, що реакція США в цій кризі була виваженою -
і жорсткою, у формі санкцій, і обережною водночас.
У цих санкціях є дві речі, які, на мою думку, привернули увагу Москви.
Перше - президент підписав розпорядження, яке дало йому широкі повноваження
накладати санкції щодо широкого кола проступків.
Друге - вперше за всю історію США піддали санкціям російський суверенний борг.
І у перспективі руки президента Байдена розв'язані для набагато сильніших санкцій.
Нарешті, було дуже розумним ходом, який, мабуть, здивував Кремль - те, що Байден
запропонував зустріч з Путіним.
Я вважаю, що Путін справді хоче цієї зустрічі.
Одна з причин - це його власний образ Росії як супердержави.
Ну, а супердержавам належить розмовляти з іншими супердержавами.
Байден вважає Путіна саме тим, ким він є, вживає дуже різкі слова щодо Путіна, зокрема називаючи його вбивцею...
І на цей останній інцидент, ескалацію на кордоні чи скупчення російських військ,
Байден відреагував дуже швидко.
Особливо якщо порівняти з деякими іншими акторами, не в останню чергу з Європейським Союзом.
Його відповідь була сильною. І далі він застосував санкції проти Росії, давши чітко зрозуміти,
що те, що робить Росія, є серйозним порушенням і у разі продовження на це будуть реагувати найрішучіше.
Зустріч Джо Байдена з Володимиром Путіним може відбутися у червні.
Той факт, що за кілька тижнів до цього адміністрація Байдена відправляє свого головного дипломата до Києва,
дає чіткий сигнал про те, що Вашингтон підтримує Україну, кажуть аналітики. І хоче ще раз почути її аргументи.
За чотири роки правління Дональда Трампа Київ зіткнувся з непередбачуваністю Вашингтона.
Тепер українцям можна покластися на послідовність американців. Але це має не лише радувати Київ.
Адже крім висловлення підтримки українцям у конфлікті з Росією,
держсекретар зажадає прискорення внутрішніх реформ,
поступу в розслідуванні резонансних кримінальних справ, подолання корупції та деолігархізації.
У березні Блінкен оголосив про персональні санкції для українського мільярдера Ігоря Коломойського.
Утім, і санкції, накладені Україною на канали Віктора Медведчука,
пов'язують з позицією нової адміністрації США.
Ми разом працювали у раді нацбезпеки в адміністрації Клінтона. Коли потрібно, він може бути жорстким.
І деяким людям у Києві, можливо, зробиться дещо некомфортно.
Тому що він буде наполягати на тому, щоб Україна проводила більше реформ,
робила серйозні кроки з викорінення корупції.
Мене дивує те, що США оголосили пана Фірташа у розшук, а Україна санкцій проти нього досі не оголосила.
Українські санкції проти Медведчука були запроваджені через 6 років після того, як їх оголосили Сполучені Штати.
Тож я очікую певних важливих меседжів.
Очевидно, що українські олігархи досі втручаються в управління країною,
мають занадто великий вплив у парламенті.
І це треба зупинити.
А для цього потрібна політична воля згори, сильніше бажання президента Зеленського
мати більш амбіційний та проєвропейський порядок денний.
Реальне верховенство права та справжню незалежну судову систему...
Україні, безумовно, потрібно зробити більше для створення повністю незалежної судової влади,
оскільки це є ключовим фактором формування сильної держави.
Деолігархізація та реформи важливі, зокрема, й для відновлення цілісності України.
Якби Україна провела необхідні реформи, стримала корупцію та вплив олігархів,
це б створило ситуацію, коли економіка може рости.
Це буде добре для українців, але також дозволить побудувати сильнішу українську державу,
більш стійку до Росії. І тоді люди на Донбасі і, можливо, навіть у Криму, можуть сказати:
знаєте, я хотів би повернутися в цю державу.
Наразі Білий дім не демонструє бажання долучатися до нормандського формату - поряд з Німеччиною та Францією.
І чи призначать уповноваженого щодо конфлікту на Донбасі, яким до 2019 року був Курт Волкер,
теж поки не відомо. Однак у врегулюванні щодо України США тепер будуть грати активнішу участь, ніж було досі.
Найголовніше, що ми маємо робити, і це стосується як США, так і Німеччини та НАТО -
нам треба діяти, щоб продемонструвати наші можливості і результати.
Наприклад, ми проведемо заплановані військові навчання у Польщі в наступні тижні.
Давайте залучимо до них Україну, щоб продемонструвати, що ми намагаємося працювати з Україною.
У нас є безпекова допомога, яку ми надаємо Україні.
Адміністрація Байдена розглядає способи посилення цієї допомоги і це гарна ідея.
Сполучені Штати не мали посла в Україні протягом двох років
та спецпредставника з питань України протягом півтора року.
Оголошення імен та призначення людей на посади буде ще одним позитивним кроком.
Ми мали б оголосити заздалегідь, які санкції отримає Росія, якщо почне нові військові дії.
Ми поки цього не зробили. Є багато речей, які б ми могли викласти на стіл,
щоб попередити Путіна про можливі наслідки для нього.
Питання вступу України до НАТО Ентоні Блінкен форсувати не буде, кажуть аналітики,
адже передусім партнери в Європі до цього не готові.
Куди реальнішою ціллю американці вважають двосторонню безпекову угоду з США.
Тим більше, що в Україні і так служить американська оперативно-тактична група.
Ця група у Яворові на Львівщині допомагає перетворювати українську армію на дієздатну силу.
Цього року Міноборони США надасть Україні військову допомогу на 125 мільйонів доларів.
Додаткові 150 мільйонів доларів безпекової допомоги вже затвердив Конгрес.
На 155 мільйонів доларів зросла і підтримка реформ, включно з оборонним сектором.